foreign
is with us in Alberta Canada hi Robert
how are you
doing well how about yourself better
than I deserve what's up
all right I'm looking to buy my first
house with my wife we have about 150 000
saved and my in-laws are being generous
and lending us about a hundred thousand
help with the down payment
that's enough for us to get a decent
town home in our area and that way we
would only owe family but at the that
payback rate they want with my laws we
have room for about a hundred thousand
dollar mortgage while staying below your
recommended 25 limit we're wondering if
it's a good idea to take the mortgage if
as a result we might stay in the home
longer or am I just trying to talk
myself into uh death
um
well it sounds like all of these
decisions are made except the last one
so I'm not sure how much I'll be able to
influence this
um because you all aren't going to like
my answer I would recommend you don't
take out a loan with your in-laws
oh really yeah
the borrower is slave to the lender and
when you owe your father-in-law money
Thanksgiving dinner tastes different
yeah all right uh this is how families
end up not speaking to each other
and it's a it's a uh they they are not
necessarily
um they probably aren't because you
didn't bring it up they're probably very
kind not controlling people
um that will all change the first time
you miss a payment
and suddenly where you went on vacation
the brand of the kids clothes matters
they're looking at every every decision
you make with money as to whether they
get paid or not they can't keep from
doing it because they're human beings
now how bitter they are angry they are
or toxic they are in response to those
situations or do could be different
depending on how wonderful people they
are but it doesn't matter you're going
to feel different your wife won't feel
as much of it as you will but you're
going to feel it
and uh so that's my speech I would not
do that I would highly recommend I will
never loan my children money ever now I
may give them some money
if I've got some extra money if I do
something like you're talking about I
would make that a gift personally but
that's pretty bold to ask for that on
your part but uh but but uh uh anyway
all of that to say yeah I would buy a
house that your down payment plus your
mortgage that you can afford would
purchase not an in-law loan but again I
Robert I have no expectation for you to
follow that advice because you guys have
already kind of discussed it you're
comfortable with it you threw it out
there like it's like I'm picking out a
shirt you didn't think about it at all
yeah and I I hope people don't miss what
you just said because the dynamic
changes when you start talking about
your in-laws doing anything for you I
remember before we got married
um we were doing some counsel we came
back from a counseling uh session pre
premarital and Stacy's father uh met us
at the door and and he had been working
through her finances
before she came into our marriage and
she had not a huge amount may have been
about fifteen thousand dollars as the
student loans and I was ready to take it
on we had already talked through it I
had no student loan debt at the time all
that to say he surprised us and he said
I'm gonna We want to give you this we
want to start you all off you know and
it was just really really wonderful very
nice yeah but even though it was a gift
Dave it was still in the back of my mind
still touches the prod button yes and
that's what I'm glad you called it that
because I it still felt like and it
wasn't my debt but it was going to be
our debt and it was in the back of my
mind like I owed him something and it
didn't turn into any kind of tension
because I got it was okay for it it was
a gift it was a complete gift but if you
had to pay that payment oh that would
have really been it's already jacking
with me just because it was a gift and I
think that's what I want people to hear
why would you want to do that exactly
exactly I I have trouble
um just as a general category in my life
I'm not as bad at it now receiving gifts
yeah I always have I'm a giver I'm
generous but uh but I I'm not real good
at receiving I'm not even good if you
pick up the tab at dinner it's I always
want to be there where do you think that
comes from I don't know Pride probably
but I I I am much more able to do that
than I am the only time I've ever gotten
in this situation personally Sharon's
dad is an absolute Saint he is an
incredible easy to get along with guy on
the planet never said an unkind word
since 40 years I've been married I've
never heard him say anything unkind
except the opposite political party
right occasionally but
um and he's wrong about that but the uh
but he's a wonderful guy and when we
went bankrupt he loaned us a little
money to get the house caught up and do
some things and um man he never said a
single thing it was all paid back
but my stomach yeah was not the same
until I got that cleared yeah it just it
you talk about you like you said jacked
with you messed with you yes and the old
joke is anybody you loan money to it
changes the relationship it does it
changes it friendship it changes your
roommate it changes your you loan money
to your girlfriend oh that screwed that
whole thing up you know uh anybody you
when you loan money to someone you
change it from whatever this mother
father
uh relationship to you know to to Master
Slave friend to Master Slave and the old
joke is if you loan your brother-in-law
a hundred dollars and he never pays it
back but he never speaks to you again is
it worth it
you know but that that's you know that
that's the kind of thing you can get
into now again I will
say clearly the way Robert presented
that I'm pretty sure his in-laws are not
toxic people that's right I think
they're probably for like Sharon's dad
but it will change well you nailed it
it'll weigh on him so let's say he's
talking about the vacation and maybe
they don't even look at him sideways but
he wonders did I see a look did I you
start start manifesting things to your
point your father-in-law never said
anything negative never has but it was
in your head that's where I came up with
the saying I think you're right
Thanksgiving dinner I think it doesn't
taste the same because I experienced
that you did I'm sitting at the
Thanksgiving table thinking about this
and he's not thinking about it yeah it
didn't bother him a bit Yeah but um
because he's a kind Master yeah and I
was a rebellious slave that's right
that's right well you know it reminds us
of our good friend Henry Cloud you know
talking about boundaries that's a
boundary that I think you're right it
should always be set don't take a loan
from Family Feud if you want to if you
want to help your children
and you have the extra money and you
want to give them some money no strings
attached no controlling
that's fine but no co-signing
for them for God's sakes don't co-sign
for people and no loaning don't loan
them money you will you will mess up
what should have been a good pure thing